- Hey everyone, this is Luka Negoita,
and I am super stoked to
be announcing the launch
of my new course on
"Data visualization
with R for Ecologists".
(upbeat music)
If you know about my last course
about the basics of R for ecologists,
then this course builds up
from there, going into
more advanced topics,
such as ggplot2! and
other really cool features
for plotting in R and RStudio.
This course will be launching
on Sunday, May 30th.
That's in less than two weeks.
And I can't tell you how excited I am
to finally have this out and ready.
If you've already pre-registered
for this course, then fantastic.
If you haven't don't worry,
there's still time.
Make sure to go to the link below,
enter your email address,
and you'll be sure to receive more updates
as we get closer to launch day,
including some special bonuses.
I'm really excited to
be sharing this with you
and look forward to seeing you there.
(upbeat music)